So now, we've done 3 main steps towards solving the problem. We understand the
inputs, we understand the outputs and we understand the relationship between the
two based on some examples. At this point, you might be ready to start coding.
But if the problem is a challenging one, you're probably not. What I'll suggest
in the next step is that you should really think about how to solve the problem
as a human. If you don't understand how to solve the problem yourself in a
systematic way, you're probably not ready to start writing the code. So let's
think more carefully about how we actually compute this. So what I would
suggest to do next is to try working through a few cases in a very systematic
way as a human. And we're going to try a difficult case that covers many of the
things that we would need to think about in an algorithm.